lo que tenemos aquí es la gráfica de
igual a la equis para el final de este
vídeo conocerás una de las ideas más
sorprendentes del cálculo y esto
refuerza la idea de que es un número
impresionante bueno empecemos con un
poco de exploración para ello tomemos
algunos puntos en esta curva que igual a
la equis y pensemos en cuál es la
pendiente de la recta tangente o dicho
otra manera cómo se ve la derivada en
ese punto así que veamos cuando es igual
a 1 o cuando era la x es igual a 1
entonces x es igual a 0
observa aquí parece que la pendiente de
la recta tangente es 1 lo cual es
bastante curioso porque es el valor que
toma la función en ese punto ahora
veamos qué es lo que pasa cuando llévale
2 bueno usemos otro color y observa
parece que la pendiente de la recta
tangente es bastante cercana 2 ok
qué pasa con esa pendiente cuando
x es igual a un medio eso pasa justo
aquí y observan parece que de nuevo la
pendiente de la recta tangente es
bastante cercana al valor en ese punto
que es igual a un medio ahora podemos
preguntarnos qué es lo que pasa cuando x
es igual a 5 bueno porque observan
parece que la pendiente de la recta
tangente es bastante cercana a 5 así que
a simple vista parece que tenemos el
caso en donde la pendiente de mi recta
tangente de la función era la x es
simplemente a la x será cierto
la respuesta la cual me parece
sorprendente es que en efecto es cierto
si tengo una función
efe de x que se iguala a la x al tomar
la derivada obtengo lo mismo es decir
que a la equis o dicho otra manera la
derivada con respecto a x de
a la equis es a la equis así que este es
un hecho impresionante en otros vídeos
anteriores aprendimos algunas formas de
definir
y esta es una nueva y es el número tal
que al elevarlo a la potencia x es decir
si define es una expresión o una función
como a la x es a que el número que le
elevarlo a la potencia x y tomar su
derivada obtienes
a la equis y si vemos esta curva y nos
fijamos en el valor de james entonces
para cualquier punto la derivada tomará
el mismo valor en game y si eso no te
parece misterioso mágico y sorprendente
pues lo es tal vez hoy a la medianoche
despiertes y en tiendas porque es esto
cierto y tal vez algunos de ustedes
están diciendo ok esto suena muy bien
pero porque es cierto esto bueno pues en
otro vídeo haremos la demostración